Friends of visual politic, the world has changed. Uh, no,
I'm not referring to the criminal.
Virus.
In this video.
We will talk about the revolution that the energy sector has experienced over
the past decade. More specifically, the dramatic boom in liquified, natural gas,
L N G,
and also how the fracking revolution has changed the balance of power that is
always behind the trade and energy resources.
In the past pundits and politicians claimed that America was running out of oil
and natural gas. There were saying it 10 years ago, five years ago,
I was hearing it all the time.
They said the United States would never again be an energy powerhouse.
They said that Americans would have to learn to get by with
much, much, much less, but you prove them wrong.
King has caused the United States to boost its natural gas production.
To the extent that since 2017,
the land of uncle Sam has been fully self-sufficient in terms of providing for
its own energy consumption.
Yeah.
But even have enough to be in a position to export it, of course,
because of its geographical location. The question as to who,
because the United States only has two neighbors to the North Canada,
a country that is also self-sufficient and guests.
And that in fact has exported large quantities of gas to the West coast of the
United States for decades. And then to the South there's Mexico,
which already receives more than half of all the gas.
It consumes by a gas pipeline from the United States.
So where can they flog the surplus?
Because the truth is the United States still has a lot.
And I mean a lot of gas leftover and that's precisely why an audit to look at
markets and other continents.
You definitely need to consider LNG liquified natural.
Yes.
We'll know, natural gas is traditionally exported through pipelines,
but there is one major obstacle to this way of transporting gas.
The oceans underwater pipelines exist,
but establishing an underwater pipeline for thousands and thousands of males and
a great depth is a terribly expensive and technically very complicated
undertaking.
So in order to be able to carry a trade between far-flung countries,
the only real alternative that exists is precisely liquified.
Yes.
In a way, similar to this technology,
this way of transporting energy has a huge advantage over pipelines as simply
manages to reach markets that are impossible to reach with a pipeline.
And the case of the United States makes this very clear.
It is the best example of how global gas markets have changed over the past
decade.
I don't think this is an isolated case.
Even countries with long traditions as gas exporters' are also targeting this
new method.
Okay. Russia,
gas strategy prioritize liquid natural gas with a more modest role for gas
prom. So the States and.
Russia, but also Australia, Qatar, Nigeria, the world is pushing hard for LNG.
Check out this chart about new liquification capability.
The blue that represents the world stands out more in recent years than the red
representing the United States.
Check it out.
Of course, if we're talking about gas,
we're talking about money to look at what fatty Bureau director of the
international energy agency says.
LNG investments hit record of 50 billion in 2019.
Do you see that.
It's $50 billion in a single year?
The global LNG market is moving more bank notes around the world's capitals than
money heist.
So the question we can ask ourselves is why is there this growing interest for
liquified natural gas and the global energy market?
What changes could it cause any international relations of the major powers?
Well, today on visual politics,
we are going to play teacher and answer these questions. But first as always,
let's take a look at.
History.
Denver.
Analogy to liquefy natural gas was not developed until the 1960s,
but the revolution the LNG has brought to market has really come along and been
developed in the last decade. In 10 years,
the volume of liquified natural gas marketed worldwide has doubled and
accelerated trends since 2016 when Australia Russia,
and especially the United States have literally flooded the global energy market
with liquified natural gas. And as we told you in previous videos,
fracking has caused the United States to increase its natural gas production by
80%, since 2005, that is,
it produces today almost twice as much gas as it dead just 15 years ago.
Something that explains why the United States has not only managed to supply its
own demands since 2017, but why it has enough to consider exploring.
Okay.
Friends,
this revolution has been such that it is completely changed the business
strategies of energy companies in the United States infrastructure that had been
designed to import to huge amounts of gas,
had to receive investments of more than $100 billion to be transformed and to
export facilities almost overnight. The goal became to liquified natural gas.
That is cool.
It to minus 162 degrees Celsius to convert it into a liquid state so that it
could be exported by huge methane.
Oh ships.
Of course, when you have merchandise ready for sale,
there was only one thing missing the buyer.
So who do you think has been the aggressive salesman responsible for placing the
U S L N G on the market? Well,
none other than president Donald Trump.
We all know him.
His tactics first, he threatens to impose tariffs, both left and right.
And then the negotiations begin in 2018.
He threatened to start a transatlantic trade war with the European union.
And what did he get?
We'll look at what the then president of the European commission, Jean-Claude,
Juncker promised an exchange for the United States,
not inputting tires on European cars.
That was my main intention to, to come.
Down to zero tariffs on industrial goods.
We've decided to strengthen our cooperation on energy.
You will build more terminals to import liquified natural gas from the
us.
And as we usually see on this channel, no sooner said than done us.
Guests went from representing a meager 5% of all liquified natural gas imported
in Tuesdays and 18 to reaching a 15% share a year later in 2019 statistics
don't lie.
And those were more or less the figures when the Corona virus arrived,
all of this came together in 2020. On one hand,
we found that Europe had had its gas warehouses,
an occupancy level of sexy percent compared to 40%. That was the usual level.
Add to that.
The productive land that all economies have suffered because of COVID-19.
And what do we find? Well, a market that is hard to say enough,
I don't need any more liquified natural gas for night.
And this is a problem as a problem because you know that president Trump treats
his allies according to his business interests, what do you want to buy from me?
Oh, you're my best friend. What? You're not buying anything. You'll be sorry.
And the truth is,
I don't think he likes to see how Europe is canceling orders for us LNG,
even if it's simply because Europe's demand, doesn't warrant more gas right now.
Well, it turns out that even in the worst moments of the coronavirus crisis,
there was a backlog of missing cargo ships and European waters looking
desperately for a gas holder to unload that.
G tankers buildup around virus hit Europe as crisis of Bates in Asia.
In any case, despite good sales data to Europe in 2019,
we must not lose sight of the fact that the country,
to which the United States exports the most LNG is none other than South Korea.
We're talking about the country.
That is the third most dependent on this fuel on the entire planet.
Its appetite for guests just keeps growing and not surely something Trump will
link because my friends, the truth is that in the coming years,
the United States will compete face to face with great exports in powers like
Qatar and Australia. For example, U S market share and sales,
Korea will double after this agreement is signed with BP.
Long-term contract.
The inputs are expected to surge to 7.9 million tons by 2025 with an
increased portion of 22.8%.
We expect to see the expansion of energy trade between the two countries,
the diversification of the natural gas adoption and the stability of natural gas
supply industry, ministry of South Korea.
And my friends. What happens in November and November, 2020 elections,
there are elections in the United States and no one dare say who will eventually
sit in the oval office.
What is certain though? And I mean,
a sure thing is that once we have overcome the bump,
we are currently experiencing with the Corona virus,
the U S liquified natural gas will continue its export boom around the world.
We're assured of this. As we are of Trump,
continuing to use gas imports and his way of doing politics for as long as he
stays in the white house.
Big news, as I promised two weeks ago,
the first shipment of LNG has just left the Cameron LNG export facility in
Louisiana, not only have thousands of jobs been created in the USA,
we are shipping freedom and opportunity abroad, Donald Trump, freedom.
And opportunities beyond its borders. One is Trump talking about, well,
actually the truth is that it's just a meaningful statement because if there was
any hostage in this episode,
it is Europe which has been held to ransom by Russian gas for decades.
So the question is, well,
Vladimir Putin let the U S liquified natural gas calmly reached the shores of
the old continent. In the beginning, we told you that he had a strategy.
So where are the battles fought in Europe? Well, same places. They always are.
Listen up.
Berlin, always Berlin.
You block of countries is the third largest consumer of natural gas after the
United States and Russia, of course, unlike in these two countries,
gas reduction within the European community has been in decline for years today,
it barely meets 15% of Europe's total consumption.
So obviously that means we have to bring in guests from outside countries,
however, all the 27 partners,
it is Germany that has the biggest demand by far I accounts for around 24% of
all European gas imports. How does Germany do this? Well,
basically 100% arrives by pipeline and 0% pare methane vessel.
And of course,
when you know that half the gas that has Germany comes from Russia,
and you're not so surprised that when Putin invades, Crimea,
no one in Berlin lifts.
Yeah.
And the worst is that this dependence on Russian gas will only increase more and
more. As Germany has voted to dispense with nuclear power from 2023 onwards.
So Germany needs to diversify its energy sources at all costs.
If he does not want to be subjected almost entirely to Moscow's wishes.
And the warnings to Berlin have not stopped ringing. Look at this latest one.
He needs more LNG to compliment renewables. IEA sets.
Between union reached a record level of liquified natural gas imports in 2019.
That is why it is very striking that Germany Europe's largest consumer of gas
has not yet opted for this type of energy and something that is even more
striking while it has a couple of projects underway.
Its main energy plan is centered on a new pipeline with Russia,
the Nord stream two and my friends,
both the United States and those who rule in Brussels have strongly opposed this
project. Why?
Because they don't want to increase Europe's energy dependence on the Kremlin
before we move on here is another,
You can see until the Corona virus arrived,
we had an expanding market and Europe and yes, as this guy, blue bar shoes,
American liquified natural gas had burst onto the scene dramatically.
But as you can see in the purple segment,
Russia is unwilling to easily seed its share Novatek is the Russian company that
is betting the most on this technology.
So Putin has realized the competition to other countries,
liquified natural gas brings to the gas prom pipelines and has already launched
its new strategy.
If the Europeans want liquified natural guests they'll have like a fight natural
gas, but it will also be Russian.
Right?
And the truth is that Russian gas has a huge advantage over us gas it's price
time,
because one of the main elements influencing the price of liquified natural gas
is precisely transport costs.
Basically the shorter distance to be covered by methane vessels, the lore,
the bill. And let's not forget that European economies need to be competitive.
And the endless respect to the cost of energy remains one of the main factors to
be taken into account. Well,
as you can see, it's going to be very,
very difficult for the European union to give up Russian guests even more.
So if we consider news like this.
Flux CS, Nova tech to build German LNG terminal by 2022 in case you're one.
During yes, this news means that Germany will receive even more Russian gas,
but what will happen to the Germans if they increased the dependence on Russian
gas, but let's just wait one moment because Russian liquified natural gas,
doesn't just look to the West. Rich to the East are also viable,
melting in the Arctic and icebreakers have made navigation to the Pacific ocean
possible for more and more days a year.
It's one of those catch 22 situations where burning gas allows you to sell more
gas at the expense of the planet.
But once their Russian gas has access to the continent that has the largest
appetite for natural gas, more importantly,
where more bank notes are spent on this energy source. Take a look at this.
Tokyo.
We're talking about liquified natural gas. We're basically talking about Asia.
This continent is the destination of almost 70% of all liquified gas traded
worldwide.
And Japan has been the largest importer on the planet by far for decades.
Just so you get an idea.
Japan alone imports more liquified natural gas than the entire European union
demand accelerated very strongly after the 2011 tsunami that caused the
Fukushima disaster and the consequent nuclear blockades. Of course,
things have changed a little bit since 2014.
Gas consumption in Japan has not only not grown since then,
but it's actually fallen by 13%. So why has demand dropped?
Because several nuclear power plants are back on lane and because Japan faces
too closely related problems,
the stagnation of its economy and the unstoppable aging of its population.
In any case, although Japanese entrance in liquified natural gas has shrunk.
The methane tankers have continued to sail full throttle through the Pacific.
I'm sure that by taking a look at this chart, you'll understand perfectly why
In this chart,
you can see the effects of supply and demand and all its splendor higher places
for Asia represented by the yellow and orange lanes, high demand,
limited production and reduced supply. As you can see,
there's a lot of difference between Asian lanes and the red ones representing
the Henry hub index, which marks the price of gas in the United States.
Since the fracking revolution, the red lane has stopped descending.
In other.
Words, selling gas in Asia is much more lucrative than selling gas in the United
States. But as we've said, Japanese demand has been in declaimed since 2004.
However, and the same time period,
liquified natural gas is international trades has grown by 45% and imports
from Asia have grown by 36%.
So the question is which country is pushing Asian demand. Well,
it'll come as a surprise to none of you that it's probably the country that
you're all thinking about.
Look at what energy consultants from wood Mackenzie have forecast.
China to surpass Japan as leading LNG importer by 2022.
Truth is that this forecast could be brought forward and become a reality
earlier this year, due to the economic consequences of the Corona virus.
[Inaudible].
Case.
But there is no doubt about is that the Asian giants awakening has caused China
to become an enormous natural gas consumer in 10 years as tripled as
consumption. And if we're talking only about liquified guests,
then its imports have multiplied tenfold. By the way, take a note here.
Australia has been doing great business with all of this,
a country that supplies roughly half of all the liquified natural gas that Shana
imports, but let's not get distracted by friends.
The most interesting thing is that Chinese imports have not yet peaked.
And the five years prior to the coronavirus,
they had been growing at 30% per year until the impact of the pandemic set.
And so with these numbers is clear China as the key market that will be
demanding liquified natural gas the most during the coming years.
This should give us something to think about. Maybe just,
maybe there's someone out there who should put their ideas about trade Wars
behind them. If they want to avoid a 25% tariff on their gas.
Look for example,
at what happened when Beijing granted tariff exemptions to several Chinese
importers.
April 7th, 2020, us restarts LNG exports to China after one year.
Friends,
the so-called phase one trade agreement locked China into a commitment to buy us
energy products. What's more than $50 billion. However,
it still maintains tariffs on us liquified natural gas,
which makes Chinese imports dependent on exemptions.
Like the one we have just pointed out. In other words,
if Trump wants the United States to become that great liquid natural gas export
energy power,
he dreams of he knows full well that his companies can't miss out on the world's
largest market,
will Trump be willing to backtrack and the trade war that is where we will leave
it. So we really hope you enjoyed this video. Please hit like if you did,
and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos.
If you had the little alarm button down there,
you'll get an update whenever we release one.
Also don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsider media podcast,
they provided the vocals and this episode, there were not my dulcet tones.
Finally,
this channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that platform.
Please,
please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you next time.
If you want to learn more about politics and world affairs,
and here's some more of my lovely voice, um,
check out the reconsidered podcast where we don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider@wwwdotreconsideredmedia.com or on Apple or
Google play or your favorite pod catcher.